hello adele is back
[Music]
the 33 year old singer is set to make
her big return to the music scene and
just shared the trailer for her first
single in nearly five years
the track is titled easy on me and is
set for an october 15th release and the
teaser features the opening piano chords
over a black and white video of adele
driving an old truck packed with
furniture and sheet music down an empty
back road
adele's last studio record 25 came out
in 2015 and she's laid pretty low since
in fact before this new announcement
adele's rarely used twitter page was
still covered with promotional photos
for 25. i don't even know why to be
honest i don't get it it seems safe to
say fans will be digging through the
lyrics for references to her split from
husband simon kaneki the grammy winner's
divorce was officially finalized in
march and now she's linked to sports
agent rich paul we're very lucky the
single announcement coincides with a
series of cryptic billboards that have
recently popped up around the world
featuring gold lettering on a dark blue
background the billboards read simply 30
which many fans assume will be the title
of adele's fourth album considering her
three previous records 1921 and 25 were
all based on her age at the time the
music was written fans also noted that
the singer recently changed her social
media profiles to include a shade of
blue that matches the mysterious
billboards i feel amazing about it adele
first teased fans about upcoming new
music while celebrating her 31st
birthday in may 2019 joking on instagram
that 30 quote will be a drum and bass
record and she reflected on the year
writing in part quote this is 31. 30
tried me so hard but i'm owning it and
trying my hardest to lean into it all
learning to really truly love yourself
is it and i've only just realized that
that is more than enough and on that
note i'll let adele send us off
[Music]
you